Is it only three letters?
– Four.
– Four!
– A, S – Oh my God!
– [LAUGHS]
– I have no idea what ASMR is.
– He couldn’t say it earlier.
– Amsr? Asmr? Asmr.
– Asmr, yeah, he’s got it now.
I know that ASMR is supposed to give you this, like, tingly feeling?
I have to whisper the whole time?
– I’m really bad at whispering.
– You’re dealing with probably the two worst whisperers.
– Yeah, seriously.
[WHISPERING]
Let’s do some ASMR with a Zippo lighter.
[LOUDLY]
Yeah, mine is super light
[WHISPERING]
– SHHHH!
– Sorry!
[WHISPERING]
– You’re destroying my ASMR vibe.
– I’m sorry!
[WHISPERING]
Mine, like, creaks.
That’s got to sound good to someone.
[CREAK]
[WHISPERING]
– Oooh!
– Oh, that is good.
[CRACKLE]
[WHISPERING]
Ohhh, that crackle is good.
It just reminds me of wind, blowing on a bonfire on the beach.
[DRAGGING]
[WHISPERING]
Ohhhhhhh…
[LAUGHS]
[CLICK]
[WHISPERING]
– How did you do that?
– I don't know.
[WHISPERING]
Now we’re gonna try to make ASMR with these objects.
This is what it sounds like brushing my hair
[TEARING]
[WHISPERING]
Oh yeah…
Steph, what do you think we’re gonna do?
[WHISPERING]
I think we’re gonna make weird, squelchy sounds.
[SQUELCHING]
[WHISPERING]
Ew, God… ugh.
[SQUELCHING]
[WHISPERING]
It’s painful.
[SQUELCHING]
[WHISPERING]
– Yeah, it is bad!
– Oh, it’s disgusting.
[WHISPERING]
Never going to be able to put lotion on my hands again.
I love it!
[WHISPERING]
If I ever worked making ASMR I would…
I would definitely not whisper. Like, I can’t.
–  You're done.
The experience was…
as strange and as satisfying as I expected.
[WHISPERING]
Ohhh, that crackle is good.